mais remercie brigitte pendant qu'
effectivement nos interlocuteurs vont
changer on était sur le recentrage des
missions de nos forces de l'ordre on a
vu qu'ils pouvaient coproduire de la
sécurité avec avec eux en parlant vrai
je salue le discours de monsieur brajeux
une fois qu'on a recentré les missions
il est peut-être temps de aussi de
revenir sur nos forces de sécurité
intérieure la police et la gendarmerie
donc je suis entouré à mes côtés nous
avons philippe goujon qui est député de
paris un des meilleurs connaisseurs de
la loi de thermidor qui nous parlera
effectivement de paris et ses
spécificités mais aussi du laboratoire
en termes de polices d'agglomération
interviendra ensuite le général van den
berghe jean michel qui a eu une
brillante carrière alternant de l'état
major dans un domaine qui nous est cher
la scène mère qui parle des finances
mais aussi un rôle opérationnel en
finissant sur une très belle région du
languedoc
et puis on a à mes côtés l'avocat
médiatisé jeune avocat thibault de
montbrial connu pour ses interventions
sur le terrorisme connu pour de gros
affaire qu'il a plaidé
et puis avec une petite particularité
c'est qu'il a il prend un certain
plaisir à défendre assez régulièrement
les policiers ou les gendarmes dans des
affaires de légitime défense
un peu plus loin nous avons essayé tout
à l'heure on parlait de jurassic du
jurassic parc technologique
le ministère de l'intérieur nous aurons
donc un chercheur qui pourra nous
éclairer sur peut-être comment demain on
peut faciliter donner des outils
technologiques facilitent en tout le
travail quotidien de nos forces de
l'ordre dont par l'eau des smartphones
des tablettes
et puis un directeur je suis heureux
d'accueillir monsieur eric le dos rond
qu'on a connus directeur à paris qu'on a
connus directeur de la police de l'air
et des frontières et que j'ai connus -
finalement jeune directeur allant
acheter lui-même des rôles r quand on
parle de technologie des rollers à
décathlon dans paris parce
qu'effectivement la demi-soeur
sion supérieur lui refuser il avait lac
la conviction qu'ils pouvaient inventé
un nouveau type de patrouille en mettant
des rollers pour des policiers
donc je suis heureux de l'accueillir ici
merci vous attendiez pas à 7
petit rappel de mémoire monsieur le
directeur je donne la parole à philippe
goujon pour qu'ils puissent nous faire
partager sa vision bien expliqué a
rapidement puisqu'on a beaucoup de
retard
la spécificité partiel et surtout nous
faire une projection sur la notion
police d'agglomération merci